there's nothing that kids enjoy more
than those splash pads oh yeah
i guess a pool would be one step up but
boy it's so good to see the kids have
that open again ted yeah i was just down
in the mountains edge
over the weekend they had the splash pad
open i think everybody was there and
what
people
it just draws us to it right bring a
towel wherever you go parents
if a kid spots a splash pad they're
going in yeah or do what chris matthews
does doing tearaways
right terry pants of the shorts
outside right now mainly clear skies
clouds off in the distance but it's
clearing up
so that's why we said mostly clear
overnight even though we had some clouds
through the day today pollen report
olive grasses
and ragweed reporting moderate readings
the tree pollen right now is
olive after it was oak previously air
quality
good for now right now 101 degrees sky
canyon and centennial hills you're hot
up there in the northwest part of valley
spring valley
and 97 the lakes included 99 north las
vegas
98 aliante 101 for the east side sunrise
manor
woody ranch at 100 even and 101 for
henderson southern highlands you're
checking in 100 degrees and mountains
edge
at 96 right now how about outside the
valley 96 for
prep 101 for mesquite 104 for laughlin
and death valley you're just getting
started
100 today well you're going to get up to
118 by the time we get to
thursday and that's the latest wait till
we see the latest guidance come in we'll
see
what the temperatures are as we get
closer to thursday
clouds are clearing out to the west as
we can see showers also
migrating to the south way off there in
utah and also
into arizona meanwhile the stronger
storms way off
just south of denver of course right
around albuquerque new mexico too winds
for
tomorrow not bad in fact we should stay
fairly light again
for those winds like we saw today a lot
of neighborhoods will be at single
digits your temperature trend however it
just goes up from here all right like we
say we're just preheating the oven
105 106 105 that's when the heat warning
is wednesday thursday and friday
and then those numbers start to drop
good to see that overnight 76 degrees
mostly clear
and pleasant 102 for tomorrow triple
digits are
back right our normal is 94 so we're
above that for sure
and we're going to keep those triple
digits for quite some time the heat
warning like we said goes into effect
wednesday morning
all the way through friday evening we'll
be on top of that for you on the news
now weather team
and then breezy winds also increase and
then windy next week with a big cool
down to the mid 90s possibly a week from
tomorrow
that's your most accurate forecast
christian back over